choisir son livre non pas à la
bibliothèque
née dans une cabine téléphonique c'est
le concept biblio boxe inaugurée en
france en novembre dernier dans le lycée
de poissy l'idée a été lancée par la
maison de l'europe avec des premiers
essais concluants il y a deux mois à
berne
c'est un peu un projet atypique parce
qu'au départ quand on a exposé
transformer une cabine téléphonique en
bibliothèque y avait des gens qui n'ont
gardé un peu de façon tiens c'est un peu
marginal un peu insolite et puis petit à
petit ils ont compris que le projet
était quand même d'une belle qualité
donc pour nos jeunes c'est
extraordinaire je pense qu'ils vont
vraiment en retirer belle leçon de vie
de d'échangés de tolérance aussi parce
qu'ils vont voir leur esprit et ça va
leur faire du bien
le projet culturel éducatif mais aussi
pédagogique a reçu le concours de
l'académie de versailles
l'opérateur de téléphonie orange donne
ses cabines téléphoniques obsolète qui
jouissent ainsi d'une seconde vie en
tant que prof d'allemand ça
m'intéressait énormément puisque
c'étaient les relations franco
allemandes
et puis mes collègues étaient partants
aussi de nos collègues l'atelier
d'ébénisterie d'art et les élèves aussi
donc du coup nous paraissait judicieux
de faire cet échange est ce beau projet
la présentation de la première
biblioblog française est aussi
l'occasion d'échanger avec nos voisins
allemands qui avaient fait le voyage
jusqu'à poissy d'ici peu ce sera au tour
des lycéens yvelinois de ces journées
outre-rhin
pour patrice ce sera la troisième fois
on va aller dans un lycée à berlin et
après on en entreprise là bas est en
fait c'est pour ça que qu'on nous
propose ce projet en même temps
on nous a parlé de ce projet à ce jour
six établissements de l'académie de
versailles participent à ce projet